a person goes to work they would be
making a mistake if they think that they
are the company and that the company is
an entity that will live forever what
they're doing is trading precious
Irreplaceable time for the things they
need to live lots of people in
California and in other places who have
made more than enough decided to make
more instead of to make better and I
don't know how you justify that the
markets just bend people in the wrong
direction and the irony the second part
is this when you do that the market then
destroys you that's why Yahoo doesn't
matter anymore because they chased the
short term at the very moment that
Google refused to chase the short term
now Google is chasing the short term and
we're seeing a different Arc of
companies coming along so even if you
want to argue that your job is to create
maximum long-term shareholder value
there's no evidence that says the best
way to do that is to race to the bottom